[SPEAKER_01]: Third of Wealsun in the evening, Jude, with the companions that he went to Helm Island with, returned to Monmurg on a Kosair.
[SPEAKER_01]: The Marines, Gouge, and Merrick are taken to the Harbor District.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jude and Paul Rivero however take another path up towards the royal palace and Jamis' palace as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: An attendant takes Paul up towards the royal palace as Jude is dropped at the front of one of Lord Jamis' offices.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just also to remind the DM real quick, I had pocketed some of the powder because I want to break it down and kind of study it later for my own edification.
[SPEAKER_00]: And also, it did not escape me that Lord Fairwind knew that I was an agent of Jameson's, so I'm like paranoid.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't want to get knifed in the side, you know, sit from the side street, so I'm on high alert because I've only been back, how long have I been back in Monmouth?
[SPEAKER_00]: Like a month and a half max?
[SPEAKER_01]: Not even that, I would say maybe a week.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, so, damn.
[SPEAKER_01]: But, I mean, you did work for Jamis beforehand.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, that's true, I guess.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, yeah, that's right.
[SPEAKER_01]: And maybe, you know, maybe your arrival kind of triggered something.
[SPEAKER_01]: Who knows?
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, I, uh...
[SPEAKER_00]: Not to the guards, or at least do they let me into the waiting room?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, no, they let you in.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you're led down a stairway down into the Harbor District.
[SPEAKER_01]: So basically what Jamis is doing is he is making sure nobody sees you coming to see him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: You realize that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Real quick, if Garrett and nobody in his group takes what's left of the barrel, because we did take one of those small barrels, I'll take it.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: The barrel is taken.
[SPEAKER_01]: The captain of the ship takes that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Actually, there are agents that are not those guys that take possession of all four barrels.
[SPEAKER_00]: I just wanted to make sure they weren't hanging out and paying attention.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's obvious that Jamis or Jeon know what they are, and they take possession of them correctly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so I get brought up to one of his offices.
[SPEAKER_00]: Have I been to this office?
[SPEAKER_01]: Actually, you're taken down to the office in the...
[SPEAKER_01]: Harbor District, the one you've been to always.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you're taken through a back way and some back stairs.
[SPEAKER_01]: I pay attention to the route.
[SPEAKER_01]: If it's a new route that I've never... You have never been through it.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's obviously a path from Lord Jamis' personal place down to his office.
[SPEAKER_01]: Probably the one he takes.
[SPEAKER_01]: But it is not lost on you that
[SPEAKER_01]: He doesn't want you to be seen, coming to be seen.
[SPEAKER_00]: Walking around the Dallas district or whatever.
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you enter his office and he's there.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he goes, Jude, please take a seat.
[SPEAKER_00]: I need a drink.
[SPEAKER_01]: I assume you're not partial to Gouge's red eye.
[SPEAKER_01]: I just make a face.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have something for you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wine?
[SPEAKER_01]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or would you like something harder?
[SPEAKER_01]: Just wine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so he pours some wine.
[SPEAKER_01]: He brings it to you and puts it down.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is a vintage from Keoland.
[SPEAKER_01]: I hope you like it.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's ships that were making these days.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or no, that was Oeridian?
[SPEAKER_00]: Was it an Oeridian ship?
[SPEAKER_00]: On Wallian.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's way beyond what Keoland can do.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, right, right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, have you had a chance to talk to Paul yet?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not going to be speaking with Paul.
[SPEAKER_01]: The prince is going to be debriefing him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Perhaps I will talk to him later.
[SPEAKER_01]: I wanted to speak with you before I spoke with Gouge or Merrick and got their reports.
[SPEAKER_01]: You want it from the beginning?
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to know a few things.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think I have a very clear picture of what occurred out there.
[SPEAKER_01]: I had observers and I had men embedded in the Marines as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: I met the ones that were with Gouge, at least.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: By the way, of which, at least two of them sound like they answer to other people.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know if you're one of those.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't need to know who they answer to, but on Gouge's crew...
[SPEAKER_00]: They answer to me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: From what I understand, Merrick is one of my agents.
[SPEAKER_01]: Gouge is one of my agents.
[SPEAKER_01]: The two Marines...
[SPEAKER_01]: The Bard?
[SPEAKER_01]: What's that?
[SPEAKER_00]: The Bard?
[SPEAKER_01]: The Bard?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, there's a Bard.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's one of the guys in Gouch's group.
[SPEAKER_01]: I see.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can't remember his name.
[SPEAKER_00]: Kind of pisses me off.
[SPEAKER_01]: I assume they were just Marines with you.
[SPEAKER_01]: They were not my agents.
[SPEAKER_01]: I will look into them, however.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's interesting.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I know that the Bard and Merrick both were the ones that sent the message to have some Corsairs meet us, that we were going to be leaving in a skiff.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, I don't know, it just seemed to me that maybe that...
[SPEAKER_01]: These must be men that Merrick trusts.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe that's it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe he's Merrick's man.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's understandable.
[SPEAKER_01]: Merrick did ask me if he could use some of his own people that he trusts, so I assume that that's what it is.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll speak to Merrick about them and ascertain their loyalty.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do I know, okay, now this is to the DM, do I kind of know that the big guy's a paladin?
[SPEAKER_00]: Did I ever see him smite?
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I mean, the thing is, is that really, I think that what Tyrus looks like to you is just a really... A big fighter.
[SPEAKER_01]: A big fighter that's really...
[SPEAKER_00]: He's afraid of water.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's afraid of water, but it's also very, very loyal to the principalities.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'd let Jameson know if I kind of overtly knew that he was a paladin, but it doesn't sound...
[SPEAKER_00]: He's just a very enthusiastic guy.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't think I saw him do anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: Very enthusiastic, pro-Jeon kind of guy.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so given that you already know some things, what is it you'd like my take on?
[SPEAKER_01]: Did Fairwind progress?
[SPEAKER_00]: I wasn't so...
[SPEAKER_00]: So when we had penetrated the inner citadel, and we were not yet discovered, Paul sent forward his homunculi, and when it came back, Paul was agitated and said, we got him.
[SPEAKER_00]: And so we moved in.
[SPEAKER_00]: My first sight of him, we had to fight first two Toli.
[SPEAKER_00]: They knew at least some magic they were able to thwart.
[SPEAKER_00]: It was either a counter spell, but they had magic weapons, rapiers and daggers.
[SPEAKER_00]: And at least what I was able to tell.
[SPEAKER_00]: And both of them are dead.
[SPEAKER_00]: We had to fight those two before we got in.
[SPEAKER_00]: And fair one was tied to a chair.
[SPEAKER_00]: In the conversation that I had that proceeded trying to get Farrowin off the island, we were going to bring him back to Monmurg, let you and Jeon treat with him or interrogate him or whatever, he did admit to having siphoned off for months the barrels.
[SPEAKER_00]: I got eyes on in the barrel room.
[SPEAKER_00]: It is completely empty and there were 25 minus the four barrels that we brought with us, 25 barrels that we were able to salvage.
[SPEAKER_00]: The rest were being shipped off and we found out that it was Kane Toli's ship, the Ghost.
[SPEAKER_00]: That it was being ferried onto.
[SPEAKER_00]: So it sounds to me like the Toli took some of those barrels and that they were trying to treat with Lord Fairwind and he was playing it off like it's business as usual that like between the princes you guys are always jockeying for position.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he did say, I heard him say, well actually no I don't think, I think I was actually, sorry, to the DM I think I was accidentally reading Paul's part so I wouldn't know that
[SPEAKER_00]: I wouldn't know that part.
[SPEAKER_00]: That was actually what Paul would have.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so I did hear him say though that he had been siphoning off and that
[SPEAKER_00]: It's like he wasn't surprised.
[SPEAKER_00]: He was either just trying to play it cool or whatever, but the Toli were there, so it does sound like Fairwinds.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think Fairwinds out for his own best benefit, and I think that he thinks if he can side with the Toli against Jeon, he can just get more leverage or more power or more control.
[SPEAKER_01]: So for him it's political play.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think it was, and that's one of the reasons why I was trying to bring him back to you guys.
[SPEAKER_00]: I figured that you could still treat with him, or negotiate with him, or ransom him back to his own people, or whatever.
[SPEAKER_00]: My sense with the Toli, just in the short time that I've been back here from, you know, being abroad for the last year, is it's, I mean, if the Toli are involved with this guy,
[SPEAKER_01]: That's what I'm afraid of.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm glad to have you tell me that Fairwind, in all honesty, admitted to the fact that he was playing politics and for leverage.
[SPEAKER_00]: I believe so.
[SPEAKER_01]: You should probably know this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fairwind and Jeon are childhood friends.
[SPEAKER_01]: They've known each other for their entire lives.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jeon
[SPEAKER_01]: And I think his mind will be changed now, especially if Paul is the one to accuse him.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm glad that that happened.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you were sent because, in truth, Prince John could not imagine that his friend would betray him such.
[SPEAKER_00]: He did literally say that he's been siphoning off those barrels and that he has maybe even the largest stash of the surviving barrels.
[SPEAKER_01]: Which is...
[SPEAKER_01]: Treasonous to the principalities, but not necessarily directly to Jeon.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, for him to be talking to the Toli, normally that would not be something that would be considered untoward.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, removing barrels of that substance is definitely treasonous.
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact, having knowledge of it
[SPEAKER_01]: Is, to those not part of the Admiralty, something that's treasonous.
[SPEAKER_00]: Toli agents should not have been allowed into that area.
[SPEAKER_00]: So they would have also come up from the bottom.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because where we found them, we didn't penetrate the citadel, we climbed one of the outer walls close to the coastline.
[SPEAKER_00]: I was able to magic them up and Gowage was obviously able to climb.
[SPEAKER_00]: And we did it under cover of darkness.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fairwind's troops were not aware.
[SPEAKER_00]: And so he had a sizable portion of his garrison that had retreated back to the garrison.
[SPEAKER_00]: Apparently under that fog that had come in a few nights ago, that's when they were hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_00]: And they were dressed in marine gear.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not any color that I know that's associated with the princess.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I thought that that was interesting and when I talked to the Fairwinds captain, at least at the garrison, he had no understanding of what had happened other than that the hobgoblins held the inner citadel.
[SPEAKER_00]: He demonstrated with the troops just a show of force that would allow us the diversion we needed to scale the outer wall.
[SPEAKER_00]: But when we had Fairwinds show us, because we were trying to save what barrels might still be left,
[SPEAKER_00]: He took us from the inner hall, the inner sanctum straight down, and it was in the inner sanctum that we fought the Toli, and given that they probably came from the ghost,
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, you're right.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, they know not only about the barrels, they also know about the entrance.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you feel like the hobgoblins were able to take the helm because they were led by Fairwind through the smuggling caves up into the helm?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not certain about that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fairwind said that he didn't want to see any of his men killed, and so he made sure that they were disarmed and locked in other portions.
[SPEAKER_00]: We left before.
[SPEAKER_00]: I was going to try to stay with Paul, but Gouge thought that it'd be wiser, and Merrick also thought it'd be wiser if we just jetted back, and, you know, that's why they called for help with the Corsairs that you'd sent, or that Jeon had sent.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I'm not entirely sure if they just came in under the cover of the fog, the sahaugin, you know that there was sahaugin there, which I guess that's what the barrels were there to prevent.
[SPEAKER_00]: We lost the entire complement of 200 Marines.
[SPEAKER_00]: I was able to
[SPEAKER_00]: Save 20 that were with us when we went ashore.
[SPEAKER_00]: And we retreated into the garrison with Lord Fairwind's men.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, to my knowledge, Lord Fairwind's men, they seem to not be aware of his duplicity.
[SPEAKER_00]: At least the ones that were on the outer.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have not talked to any of the ones on the inner.
[SPEAKER_00]: But it didn't sound like there was a massacre of his men.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have a feeling that what Lord Fairwind was trying to do was to
[SPEAKER_01]: Keep up a ruse to where he was, his theft of the barrels would go unnoticed.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he could blame it on the Toli.
[SPEAKER_01]: That would make sense.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, unfortunately I think that there are a couple of things you should be aware of.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'll let you know this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Don't speak to anybody of this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not even Gouge.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or Paul?
[SPEAKER_01]: Not even Paul.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: In truth,
[SPEAKER_01]: Prince John's love of Feralint had blinded him once, and I'm afraid that his emotions in this situation will blind him again.
[SPEAKER_01]: So therefore, when we act, we have to do so without those blinders.
[SPEAKER_01]: And therefore, what I say to you is between you and I.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is not because I trust you greatly, Jude.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, I think you understand what patronage is.
[SPEAKER_01]: And times are desperate.
[SPEAKER_01]: And my patronage will pay greatly.
[SPEAKER_01]: For you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Got another magic ring in that drawer?
[SPEAKER_01]: What'd you say?
[SPEAKER_00]: Got another magic ring in that drawer?
[SPEAKER_00]: I just chuckled.
[SPEAKER_01]: He goes, he says, well, in all actuality, I have something probably better than that, something that you would like.
[SPEAKER_01]: Real estate is actually very cheap right now in Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I know where you live.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you may have reason to be there for various nefarious reasons.
[SPEAKER_01]: I do not judge.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think that what you are doing is keeping your thumb on the pulse of the foreign district.
[SPEAKER_01]: I understand that.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, there is a tower that overlooks the sea that I think you would be very well appointed in.
[SPEAKER_01]: And of course,
[SPEAKER_01]: I understand that access to the Royal Library would be something that you would most definitely appreciate.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is not the Archives of the Arcane Order, which is in Port Toli, of course, but this library is not bad.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's more than I had in the D.
[SPEAKER_00]: Which was a half destroyed tower.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we will see that happen as long as you're willing to act as my agent in this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, I don't think Fairwind fully understands what the Toli are up to.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't think he understands what the Scarlet Brotherhood actually is.
[SPEAKER_01]: He does not understand the danger associated with that.
[SPEAKER_01]: He doesn't
[SPEAKER_00]: I think he's playing politics.
[SPEAKER_00]: With people that are playing for keeps.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he believes that the Toli ultimately want to see the sea principalities as a unified nation.
[SPEAKER_01]: Their negotiation with Prince Jeon is about slavery, with the Duke of Berghof, the Duke of Berghof, the plar of
[SPEAKER_01]: Westfort, and the interior of the principalities.
[SPEAKER_01]: He thinks that Prince Jeon's objections to that trade are the only things that the Toli are interested in.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's not true.
[SPEAKER_01]: And unfortunately, I think Prince Jeon himself doesn't fully understand what the Toli are doing.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've gotten information that the Scarlet Brotherhood are not only infiltrating the Sea Principalities, they're also infiltrating Keoland.
[SPEAKER_01]: And that the current conflicts
[SPEAKER_01]: Between Keoland and the Sea Principalities are being stoked by the Scarlet Brotherhood to their benefit.
[SPEAKER_00]: Remember when I talked to that Baron of Redlaw?
[SPEAKER_00]: Red Shore.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I had mentioned to you that he seemed surprised that I told him that Jeon, Prince Jeon, was against slavery.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because they were thinking, or he was believing that Gradsul and them were taking up this cause.
[SPEAKER_01]: That is directly from the Duke of Gradsul.
[SPEAKER_01]: The Duke of Gradsul has always said that the Sea Principalities are morally debased because of their practice of slavery, which has occurred in Berghof since before the Sea Principalities even existed.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's been something that has been there since the fall of the Suhl Empire.
[SPEAKER_01]: We have nothing to do with it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, slaves are traded in our marketplaces and Giong would see it ended, but unfortunately it's been something that's predated our nation.